so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics I'm your host car
Smallwood yes that is oh no my prop
Skellington I'm your host car Smallwood
and today we're talking about
Neanderthal the origins Evolution
Extinction of Humanity's closest
relative oh no my prop my prop
Skellington you know I'll just I'll just
hold my Skellington there we go I just
thought you know skeleton be funny and
this video is based on original article
submitted To Us by Radu
Alexander
the date was 1856 and some miners were
Excavating limestone in the Feld hover
caves in the neander valley near doel
off like their predecessors have been
doing for centuries during the dig the
workers unearth some bones no big deal
right just you find bones everywhere and
they thought it's probably just a bear
or something so they discard the bones
with the rest of the debris one of
History's Greatest discoveries was
almost confined to the garbage dump of
history but unfortunately the mind's
owner the awesomely named William
beckoff saw the bones and was intrigued
by them his instincts told him that
there was something to these bones other
than just being the remains of an animal
or something so he T them to the closest
thing to a scientist he could find a
local school teacher who was an amateur
fossil collector in his spare time by
the name of Johan Carl fot to his credit
fot could immediately tell from
examining the skore capat that he was
looking at something special he looked
human but not too human the low forehead
The prominent brow ridges the sturdy
bones they all suggest that this was a
different kind of person altogether but
still let's not get carried away after
all full R was school teacher not
exactly an expert in the field so he
packed the bones and traveled to Bon
where he consulted with a professor of
anatomy called Herman sha Housen and he
confirmed what forat expected they were
looking at the remains of a primitive
type of human the Neanderthal had been
discovered so the duo did not
immediately go public with their
Discovery after all as far as the entire
world was concerned this was the first
ever fossil of an archaic human it
wasn't the kind of thing you just
casually announce like next week's
cafeteria menu the pair made the
announcement in 1857 and published their
findings just a year later but they were
not taken too seriously by the
scientific community at large as we
mentioned no other remains of extinct
human species have been found by this
point and it was even a few years before
Charles Darwin published On the Origin
of Species and evolution was hardly a
widely held view in many scholarly
circles as for the various
idiosyncrasies of the bones they were
largely dismissed as being malformations
belonging to a disease but otherwise
unremarkable human history full rot and
sha Houser needed two things then in
order to gain scientific approval one
was recognition from a more eminent
figure in the field and they got it in
the form of renowned Scottish geologist
Charles Lyle who examined the bones and
concluded that they were of very very
old age and the other was more fossils
if these remains truly belong to a
primitive species of human then there
should be morees around right should be
find some more bones go digg in well as
it turned out not only were there other
fossils about but they'd already been
discovered bones belong to two different
Skellington have been found in Belgium
while a skull that was fully intact have
been discovered in jalter decades
earlier however it seemed that none of
them had a local school teacher who
dabbled in collecting fossils there was
nobody to recognize the importance of
the fight even so with all this talk of
a new species of human knocking about
people remembered that they had these
fossils just sitting there and decided
to know get them out for closer
inspection these remains were also
intriguingly distinct from those of
modern humans slowly but surely the idea
that we might be talking about an
archaic type of human dis from Homo
sapiens was gathering steam finally in
1864 the fossils were recognized for
what they truly were the remains of a
different species of human he was even
given a name Homo Neanderthal anes which
we're just going to call Neanderthal for
the rest of the video because that's
that's what you know right you know
Neanderthal did you really know it was
homo Neanderthal Anis I didn't know I
had to look up how to pronounce it like
I just saw I thought it was Neanderthal
anyway as you can probably tell the
species were named after the German
Valley where the fossil of Neanderthal
one as he came to be known was found
technically CLE the bones in Belgium
were the first to be discovered but
since Neanderthal one was the one who
kicked off the whole Hol who decided
that he would become the type specimen
for his species and with that the field
of paleoanthropology was
born a study of Neanderthals has been
going on for over a century and a half
and it's still very much A continuing
process as a general rule we're not
going to go over each individual
Discovery in advancement and place them
chronologically because that would only
make things more confusing and now that
we've said that let's immediately break
that rule by looking at what happened in
the Years following the establishment of
Neanderthal 1 as a separate human
species over the next few decades more
remains of Neanderthals were discovered
mainly in Europe but also in Southwest
Asia even so not everyone was on board
with the whole extinct human species
thing and some prominent Scholars
delayed the S neanderthals by arguing
that the bones they kept finding simply
belonged to a deceased and deformed Homo
sapiens mildly interesting for sure but
hard is something to revolutionize our
understanding of humanity as a whole
eminent German Pathologists Rudolph
viral were was particularly guilty of
this faulty reasoning and he was
convinced that rickets and arthritis
were responsible for the physical
abnormalities of the neanderthal remains
with that in mind the opposite Camp
which remember argued that neander falls
were indeed a distinct and extinct
species of primitive human received a
giant boost to strengthen their case in
1908 when they discovered the hope I'm
pronounce this correctly La Chappelle or
St ju simply known as the old man as his
name suggests it was found in LA
Chappelle of saints a communist central
France and it was the first almost
complete skeleton of Neanderthal ever
discovered the skull in particular was a
real finds it promly displayed the heavy
brow Rider protuding midface and low
receding forehead that is typical of the
species The Remains were found to be
around 60,000 years old but the actual
age of the old man when he died is still
a bone of contention always a fan of
Skellington puns some say he was around
40 years old While others argue that he
was much older since the bones along the
gums had begun to regrow after he lost
several teeth something that would
normally take decad Ates some Scholars
even speculate that the condition of the
old man's teeth made it impossible for
him to chew his own food and that
someone else probably grounded it up for
him they saw this as the first sign that
neanderthals were not quite as primitive
as initially thought and that they lived
in an altruistic Society where they
helped and cared for each other but more
on that later unsurprisingly the old man
was a landmark moment for our
understanding of Neanderthals but at the
same time it also created a common
misconception that goes on to this day I
think I know which one this is It's that
neanderthals like like this they like
you know me like you know your resident
fact Goblin if we have to point the
finger at someone then we have to point
it at marcelin Boule the French
Anthropologist who the first to study
the old man he was the one who assembled
the skeleton but he didn't make it look
like a modern human even though he
really should have in his mind
neanderthals were brutish dimwitted
primitive creatures more closely
resembling gorillas than us so he made
the old man with a severely curved spine
a stooped stance with bent knees forward
flexed hips and the head juted forward
he even gave the Reconstruction
opposable toe like the great apes and
this image of Neanderthals survives to
this day despite being widely dismissed
as inaccurate this is still how people
perceive neanderthals and the image is
pretty far removed from the reality like
well it is true that the old man
suffered from osteoporosis which would
have impacted his posture but modern
experts still believe that Boule should
have known better and that he let his
own preconceptions cloud his judgment
and affect his work when assembling the
Skellington in reality neanderthals were
physically quite similar to us Recent
research suggests that they even had a
gen that causes red hair on average
their bodies were shorter and stockier
and they had larger noses and a distinct
double arched brow but many scholars
argue that if you was takeen Neanderthal
man give him a shave a haircut put him
in a nice suit most people would find
him indistinguishable from any other man
on the street who had a podcast now of
course we're only talking about the
physical traits that go Skin Deep here
if you were to start to delve into the
nitty-gritty of Neanderthal Anatomy
there's plenty of differences between
them and us for example any bone expert
could immediately tell if remains belong
to an Neanderthal or a modern Human by
looking at the skull or the pelvis which
are noticeably different strangely
enough another reliable way of telling
our species apart is the middle ear the
three tiny bones we have in there are
vital in our hearing but are more
distinct between Homo sapiens and
Neanderthals than they are between the
chimps and the
gorillas despite our extensive research
into the origins and evolution of homon
neand alanes it is still pretty much a
vast and dark cave of knowledge into
which we catch occasional glimpses of
Lights we to stress that a lot of this
information is still not universally
agreed upon but it does represent our
best understanding at the moment so you
know if you're watching this 10 years
down the line hey is everything still on
fire let us know in the comments so
contrary to what some people might think
neanderthals are not our ancestors they
are more like a distant cousin is he
instead believe that we both evolve from
the same ancient ancestor perhaps homo
hyle bis I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly they might also be the
ancestor of a third homon species called
The donovian Who have only been
identified for the first time back in
2010 just to show you that major
discoveries in paleoanthropology are
still happening quite regularly the
Divergence between our predecessors and
the anals might have happened sometime
around 400,000 to 500,000 years ago as
we already mentioned not everyone is on
board with this line of thinking for
example a group of scientists dropped
the equivalent of an anthropological
bombshell in 2016 when they announced
that they had recovered the oldest
neanthal DNA in the world from some
bones at Sim henos in Spain at PCO
mountains dated to approximately 4
30,000 years ago they wanted to push
back the Divergence of neander Falls
from their ancestors a few hundred
thousand years this would have made it
far too early for our common ancestors
to be the aforementioned homo hleb genis
but just right for another extinct
species called homo antecessor so there
is now a distinct group of Scholars who
believe that hom Anessa was the last
common ancestor between us and the
Neanderthals not uh again I'm want to
try and pronounce this one last time H
highle bis and the two sides get along
about as well as the Jets and the Sharks
but with far less dancing and far less
clicking so the only solution is of
course a dance battle in the middle of
the street followed by a knif fight so
we joke but we might not be sure when
neanderthals first appeared we have a
pretty good idea of when they died out
it seems that their numbers start to
plummet dramatically around 40,000 years
ago and very few traces have been found
that are more recent than that that
being said some pockets of Neanderthal
civilization may have stuck around for a
while the most significant being in
jalter proponents of this idea believe
that the goram's cave in jalter was the
last the fall society and that homed
cousins managed to survive there until
28,000 years ago before finally going
extinct the Heyday however was around
100,000 years ago give or take 10,000
years they lived all over Eurasia
inhabiting regions stretching from
England going all over Continental
Europe into Central Asia and as far east
as Siberia when our ancestors hopped
over the Mediterranean Sea from Africa
into Europe the two groups collided and
yes in case you're wondering they did
get their freeon so they did do the
horizontal nasty in the past day so most
research seems to indicate that modern
humans and Neanderthals inter bread
which is why many people today still
have a bit of Neanderthal DNA in their
genetic code and this has its ups and
downs after mapping the human genome we
saw this DNA is associated with skin and
hair possibly making us hairier and
sturdier to survive colder climat while
also being involved in boosting our
immunity systems on the other hand the
andell DNA seems to be closely
associated with certain illnesses such
as diabetes lupus and Crohn's disease if
you have to suffer with any of those you
can blame the Andals which is a weird
sentence to say but yet it could be
true going all the way back to bou's
interpretation of Neanderthals which
shaped our perception of our primitive
cousin we developed quite a low opinion
of them basically we looked at
neanderthals as nothing but a hunched
over grunting Savage who was close to an
ape than he was to us human but ever
since then most discoveries we've made
about neanderthals would suggest pretty
much the exact same opposite that they
were intelligent and had a culture that
was on power with our at the time their
brains oddly enough were bigger than
ours in proportion to body size but then
again so were the brains of ancient Homo
sapiens so that alone isn't saying much
but neanderthals go up to the same stuff
as our ancestors we know they like to do
a bit painting not just on Cave walls
but in order to decorate their own
personal items for example there's a
36,000 year old King scallop shell
recovered in Spain that had been painted
with red and yellow ion oxide minerals
this was before Homo sapiens came to the
region so it had to be the Neanderthals
unless the Bears in that area
particularly artistic there also so
wasn't any practical purpose to this
which means that the anells sometimes
just like things because they were shiny
and pretty the shell itself was also
probably just used as a pendon which
wouldn't be the only example we found of
modified jewelry cave walls were
unsurprisingly neanderthals favorite
medium although it seems that the
Primitive artist was more of an engraver
than a painter dozens of such Engravings
have been found in the pic sites across
Europe in the Middle East alternatively
dated to a time before Homo sapiens came
onto the scene the oldest one of all is
approximately 57,000 years old and is
found in caves Lair Valley was only
announced a short while ago in June 2023
once again showing us that new
developments are always happening in the
study of our long lost cousin ancestors
if we were willing to wade into the
murky waters for a bit we could make the
highly controversial and still doubtful
statement that neanderthals even had a
musical sight to them Scholars have
found multiple bone flutes which are
tens of thousands of years old and the
debate rages on of whether they were
made by neanderthals or Homo sapiens
remember we did coexist for a Time One
flute in particular known as the D bab
flute is said to be about 60,000 years
old it was Unearthed in Slovenia in 1995
and it's made out of a thigh bone of a
Cave Bear if the age of this flute is
correct then it would not only be
undoubtedly of neanthal Origins since
our ancestors hadn't made it to Slovenia
yet but it would also be the oldest
musical instrument in the world as we
said this is a hot tank that sure to
Rubble Rouse the scientific community so
take it with a large pinch of bony salt
their crafting skills were also up to
Snuff relative to the time period they
lived in we have recovered all sorts of
Neal tools and weapons ranging from
Precision Tools like small blades and
scrapers to mediumsized hand axes and
lar Spears used for hunting Stone was
unsurprisingly their material of choice
but they also doubled in woodworking
they process animal highights for
clothing and even also used organic
tools such as shells and pomis Stones
one particularly interesting Discovery
in a cave in Israel suggests that they
might have even recycled torto shells to
use as rudimentary containers which
makes sense B bong is better than hand
and the one thing that Neals did not do
though is develop long range Weaponry
all signs indicate that their Hunters
like to go up close and personal with
their prey even when they were taking on
big game like Mammoth and bears they
preferred to grip a large thrusting
spear with a lot of power behind it
instead of something more versatile and
light like a bow and or Arrow they might
have made smaller spear that could have
been thrown but definitively no bows or
arrows have ever been found now nowadays
some research believe this could have
contributed to their eventual Extinction
once modern humans came along and the
two groups began competing for the same
resources our use of bows and arrows
made us far more success successful
hunters and left less food for an
Neanderthal cousins also like you know
short squat like we know like you know
fantasy literature has taught this like
you know if you're short on a squat like
a dwarf you use like hand Weaponry
you're tall and Alive like an elf use a
bow and arrow just science we arrive now
at one of the most contentious points in
regards to the study of Neanderthals not
that anything we've said so far has been
a slam dunk funeral rights now we know
that neanderthals did intentionally bury
their dead at least on rare occasions
but was there any kind of symbolic or
religious meaning behind it was there
some kind of ceremony or did they just
dig a hole and chop them in so for
decades it's been suggested that NE anal
burials were simply practical if they
could have been bothered to do them at
all this was in line with the common
view of Neanderthals as primitive and
animalistic but one cave in Iraq might
change all of that forever it's called
the shanidar cave and it's been an
absolute godsend Anthropologist for over
half a century thanks to the many
remains and artifacts discovered at the
site but there's a recent find that
might be the biggest one of all the
skeleton of Neanderthal man that has
been subjected to a so-called flower
burial clusters of pollen were found in
the soil he was buried in suggesting
that others threw flowers into his grave
this would be the first sign of any
funerary right practiced by Neanderthal
what Skeptics point to the pollen and
saying it could have come from borrowing
rodents or insects or even from the
people Excavating the site itself so we
just quite simply do not know for
sure finally we arrive at the big one
why did Neanderthal go extinct and to
put it plainly we don't now scientists
have been researching this answer for
decades and we're still nowhere near a
consensus obviously the strongest
inclination is to blame us for wiping
out the Neanderthals unfortunately we do
tend to be pretty good at that sort of
thing and the timeline also does
unfortunately line up quite well
neanderthals had lived in EUR Asia for
hundreds of thousands of years and then
bam 40,000 years ago poof they disappear
whether or not they still survived in
small pockets is Up For Debate but they
certainly disappear from the vast
majority of their habitat and
coincidentally this is just around the
time when Homo sapiens crossed into
Europe from Africa we out competed them
for food resources and shelter we could
have brought along some fancy new
diseases that there had no immunities
towards or we could have simply fought
and killed them all and it could have
been a nice little mix of all three but
the end result was the same scor or the
win for Homo sapiens one recent
hypothesis proposes the exact opposite
though it says that the Andals died out
because they made Love Not War
specifically argues that in breeding
with Homo sapiens on a large scale is
what eroded the neanthal populations to
the point of Extinction this goes
against the current General consensus
which say is that although the two
groups did mingle very diplomatic
language used there from time to time uh
it was only a casual thing and it would
not have led to any serious effect on
their population numbers so this is very
much a new and controversial idea but
there's another one that's been going
around for a while and it's picked up
some steam in recent years instead of
blaming us this notion claims that
climate change drove the Neal's
Extinction specifically a Thousand-Year
Long Cold Snap that occurred in Central
Europe around 40,000 years ago which
would have led to a massive habitat
degradation and fragmentation for the
Neanderthals even before Homo sapiens
made it out of Africa this same model
asserts that this cooling period did not
affect the areas inhabited by our
ancestors as severely so when the two
sides finally met we already had a giant
Advantage going into it numbers of the
time Homo sapiens made it to Europe the
anal populations had already dwindled
significantly and those who were left
were no match for Superior numbers and
advanced for the time technology that
technology being a stick but stick that
go far so these are the facts as best we
know them and even though we know more
about neanderthals than any other
extinct species of hominids the gaps in
our knowledge are still quite severe in
a few decades or even a few years many
of them might not even be true anymore
replaced with new ideas as our
understanding of our extinct cousins
keep evolving so thank you for tuning
into this episode of biographics as
noted at the start this video is based
on original article by Radu Alexander
and I've been your host Carl Smallwood
you can find links to both our socials
below this is oh God this is bonely um
this is a mascot from my own Channel
fact fiend with Carle sward and since
we're heading into spooky month soon he
will making many many appearances in our
content so if you want to see more for
myself and bonely check out the links to
my own channels below finally if you
enjoyed this video you liked it leave a
like if you got something to say about
it let us know in the comments in
particular my hosting and presentation
style which I've been working on trying
to refine in the last few weeks so yeah
Alo but the comments about my hair like
come on lay off a personal appears like
have you any idea how hard is to take
this main it's not great and also I'm
not shaving it to look like Simon so i'
got a big square head like a Lego man
either way if you want to see more
content like this subscribe and as
always I hope everyone out there has the
day they deserve and
cheers also yeah I know I've been a
mispronounced Skellington I
mispronounced skeleton as Skellington a
lot I just find skeleton a fun word to
say Skellington there we go you have a
good day
bony there we go
oh